the national debate over racism is also
highlighting something else the glaring
inequalities in corporate America out of
the 500 largest companies in this
country only five are run by black CEOs
Mellody Hobson is the co CEO and
president of Ariel Investments she has
pushed for more diversity in corporate
America for years now she is also on the
board of JPMorgan Chase Starbucks and
kwibi and we should point out that
Viacom CBS is an investor in kwibi but
we've got melody joining us now let's go
right to our melody good morning there's
so much to talk about right now and I
think the thing we should begin with is
is that good morning is that discrepancy
between all of these corporations
including very big ones coming out and
supporting the black lives matter
movement but then if they hold up a
mirror they don't have many executives
of color in their upper reaches where is
the disconnect there you point out an
excellent point and that is that words
are cheap they're talking about this
issue now they have to back it up this
issue has been one where we've seen more
lip service than elbow grease in my
opinion and companies right now have to
get their houses in order people are
going to hold these institutions
accountable and the place that it starts
is the Board of Directors the Board of
Directors have to hold the leaders of
these organizations accountable around
these issues of diversity which they
state on their own are vital to the
long-term success of the business so how
would that work
you mentioned CEO pay packages
potentially being tied to outcomes on
diversity how would you reward meeting
those targets in corporate America we
know a lot about incentives and you get
what you incent and so first and
foremost we need incentives around these
issues of diversity but we have to start
with the math I love the saying math has
no opinion so what do we need to do
count
we've to count and start with people
look at people across your organization
across ethnicities from the top to the
bottom what do the numbers look like and
you must set targets we're also very
two targets next look at your purchasing
where do you do your business
are you inclusive of minority businesses
and last the third P philanthropy where
do you give your money now we're hearing
a lot about philanthropy right now but
to me that's the tail that's wagging the
dog that's external we need to go back
internal again fix your own house you
made a rise in corporate America when
you think about your own experiences and
if you could talk about it for us
are there obstacles or challenges that
you came across that could be removed as
we change these policies and open up a
corporate America to a broader set of
workers well some of it is just actually
just a point of view that people have
oftentimes when you walk into a room you
have to prove yourself you have to show
that you're smart and that's unfortunate
that the burden of proof is on you the
african-american executive I think for
me perseverance persistence hard work
those things made a huge difference and
just for my own well-being I often
remembered that my plight is not as hard
as that of my ancestors I think about
that fact on my worst day I'm not in a
field picking cotton and that really
does keep me centered on the job that is
at hand
in terms of removing these obstacles
counting will make a difference if you
can see people talk about being
colorblind I did a TED talk in 2014
about being color brave don't ignore
someone's ethnicity their diversity etc
see it because if you see it then you'll
miss you'll understand where it's absent
in your own surroundings yeah I can
imagine some people being threatened by
that by that idea though they say look
if we just treat everybody equally then
the outcomes will speak for themselves
if we start seeing people and being
color brave as you say isn't that a kind
of reverse racism that's the phrase I
can imagine being shouted at the TV
right now what do you say to that I wish
people were treated equally but that's
not the case in our society there is
systemic racism in our society recent
events in the civil unrest that we've
seen in the streets proves it not to
mention the fact that I know when I walk
in the room my race is one of the first
things that people see
black first and so to say that you could
be colorblind to say that all things are
equal I think is is just not it's just
not true it's just not the way the world
works yeah what's the timetable
realistically that we should hold
corporate America to to make these
changes certainly there's a sense of
urgency right now and I think we have to
capture this moment it's very very
important that we not let this moment go
so I think right now corporations need
to do the work to understand they again
need to set the targets not just make
the statements but hold their their
leaders accountable and I think if we do
that we could see a dramatic change in
the next three to five years and that
change will be meaningful for
generations to come
yeah right now melody it seems we have a
lot of talk and not a lot of action but
you've got some good ideas for turning
that talk into action Mellody Hobson
thank you very much I appreciate you
being with us